white house correspondent peter ducey
starts us off tonight live on the north
lawn good evening peter
good evening brett and for the first
time since may walking through the press
room to get out here to the live shot
position
everybody inside is wearing a mask the
vice president hosted an event late this
afternoon
she kept the mask on the whole time so
did everybody else in the building as
new signs are going up inside the white
house that say
masks are now required even for the
fully vaccinated that is to comply with
this new cdc
guidance this is not
a decision that we or cdc have made
lightly
this weighs heavily on me president
biden says
more vaccinations and mask wearing in
the areas most impacted by the delta
variant will enable us to avoid the kind
of lockdowns shutdowns school closures
and
disruptions we faced in 2020. unlike
2020 we have both the scientific
knowledge and
the tools to prevent the spread of this
disease we are not going back to that
but he's still searching for ways to
reach the unvaccinated
if those other 100 people got vaccinated
we'd be in a very different world
so get vaccinated if you haven't you're
not nearly as
and if people who work for this
country's largest employer the federal
government
aren't vast that may soon be required
it's under consideration right now this
map shows areas most immediately
affected by today's masking update
counties with substantial or high covet
19 transmission
substantial is orange and high is red
and when it's time to go back to school
cdc recommends that everyone in k-12
schools
wear a mask indoors including teachers
staff students and visitors regardless
of vaccination status that's going to be
a tough sell
in some states i could tell you the
folks back home are done with mask
if you've been vaccinated or you've had
the virus i really don't see the science
behind insisting people wear masks the
cdc argues the vaccinated may not get
sick but they can
spread some vaccinated people infected
with the delta variant
after vaccination may be contagious
and spread the virus to others and with
that today's guidance represents
another step backwards why did the
president say
if you've been fully vaccinated you no
longer need to wear a mask
let me repeat let me repeat if you
are fully vaccinated you no longer need
to wear a mask
if it was possible that that was going
to turn out not to be true
well peter i think we're all dealing
with an evolving virus
where there's no playbook and no
historic precedent
this new guidance amounts to the biden
administration realizing that
unvaccinated people are still
getting sick and then admitting that
even if you
got the shot and did everything else
that they asked you to do since they
took
office six months ago so that someday
you could ditch the mask
they don't think it was enough right
what about the legality peter for
employers
to require people workers to get
vaccinated
the biden doj has looked at this they
think that is
legal the office of legal counsel at the
doj
checked to see if these people who
challenge vaccine mandates because the
vaccine man
because the vaccines still are not fda
approved and use an emergency
authorization can opt out and keep their
jobs and the doj's understanding
of the food drug and cosmetic act is
that such vaccine mandates
are legal memos like this are not
legally binding but we can expect
them to be folded into court challenges
to come brett pierre ducey live on the
north lawn peter thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else